personally can't afford to retire he
worked all his life at a local hospital
and now collects use items to sell on
the street but no one buys anything
these days made the market here is dead
there's nothing to sell it's been almost
a month now since I have sold anything
that's a reflection of Eric's declining
economy which has been made worse by
months of protests in Baghdad and the
southern provinces and increased tension
between the United States and Iran but
there's also a caretaker government
which doesn't even have the power to
pass the budget at Milan and we have
issues with the budget security economy
we have plenty of complicated issues all
that needs a strong government and a
strong state uncertainty makes people
want to spend less and that's bad news
for daily earners like Bakr and his
helper he's already quit his job as a
taxi driver because of traffic jams and
security issues now he's struggling to
sell vegetables the problem is that
nothing has changed it has gone from bad
to worse life is becoming harder every
day go and see the shops all will say we
do not have work everyone is suffering
all are suffering analysts say any
embargo on trade and energy from Iran
will add to the suffering of the people
the unilateral sanctions imposed in the
1990s only ended up creating hunger and
deprivation among Iraqis the u.s.
president's warning of sanctioning Iraq
if it goes ahead with plans to force out
US troops coupled with additional
sanctions on Iran has business owners
concerned in 2015 the United States
temporarily suspended Iraqi central
bank's account in New York because of
concerns that the money was going to
Iran in February a special provision
which allows Iraq to circumvent US
sanctions on Iran will expire almost a
third of Iraq's power supply is imported
from Iran is electricity in gas Iran is
also a major trade partner with more
than 30 billion dollars worth of imports
every year but Iraq's government is
optimistic about its relationship with
the US and says Washington cannot afford
to sever Baghdad
what they've been a part with you Iraq
has strong relations with the US
government on financial political
economic and military levels I don't
think the US will risk those the u.s.
cannot lose Iraq the budget for 2020
came with high rate of deficit but after
intervention by the PM himself the
deficit was lowered down to less than 20
billion dollars but for almost 40
million Iraqis the claims of reforms
with no concrete actions yet taken do
not bring relief or any certainty
personally has heard it all before
promises of improvement made and broken
for decades Osama bin Javed al Jazeera
Baghdad